where he aligns with Republicans to deplatform me. I'm the one
who's going out and and trying to get people to door knock for
Democrats. He's the who is again aligning with Republicans to
deplatform me. Blame President Trump for Charlie Kirk's assassination.
Call for more conservative deaths at rallies. Wish for the death
of Deon Nunes. How does Alex Jones not include the child stuff
in here? >> Hassan has lost his seven figures in ad revenue
because of me and you can't do [__] about it. Remember
to let Hassan know that he lost seven plus figures of revenue
from me.
I've got one Hassan segment I wanted to watch here today. >> Best
friend of mine would say that I
>> Come on. He had to have Hold on. Let All right. I got
one Hassan clip I wanted to watch or just a section of his VOD
here. Hassan versus all of the correct people. Well, maybe not
all of the correct people. Okay. >> Like the mafia. >> Just
going to react to Hassan doing a little drama today. All right.
He kind of on Dan on Motorbox. He on Noxaku. Okay, we check it
out. >> One must ask, >> oh, the Dan comment you
just sent me is deleted. Unlucky. >> Does this help you?
Dear Ilam, sir, Hassan [__] calls the death of Senator
Tom Cotton. A tweet on X. Senator Rick Scott, landlords, fascist.
He made five plus videos on YouTube calling you an by the way.
Zionist, he means says someone's got to do it regarding Trump.
Literally,
none of this is true, but it doesn't matter. He also plays terrorist
propaganda videos stated upon support for terrorist groups.
Ironically enough, he's talking to >> stated upon stated
open support for >> Elon Musk where the videos are on Elon
Musk platform. For the record, he would support an IRA style
terrorist organization in the USA to fatigue the population regarding
support for Israel. He's clearly protected due to his constant
violation of toos
punishments and then it's like all petty
madeup grievances.
I have evidence for each point if you'd like to see more. Maybe
you can do something because no one else will. God bless. >> Dear
Mr. Elon Musk. Sir, please. Elon, please. Elon, could you please
get this guy? Look, here's all the bad things he did. Elon, please.
Stealthily justifies the assass assassination of Charlie Kirk,
calling him a fascist radical.
This is
>> This is the same guy that u said this. The reason why
we were looking at this is because >> Oh, he wants to go
to the as a tweet or
>> where's the tweet he wants to go to? >> That same.
Hi here.
>> Said this and by the way it might not >> Hi here.
I uniquely get from the far right and the far left and I can
say with 100% certainty I would entrust my life to a anti-semitic
Nick Fuentes Groper named 42069
over a moderat moderately leftist college student who that goes
to overwhelmingly peaceful protests and celebrates Charlie Kirk's
assassination. That's how bad it
That's how bad it is. Uh this is I I don't know what's going
on on the internet when somebody can write this statement and
like not like he's not doing a bit. This is like his sincere
opinion. His sincere grifting opinion, but it's like the thing
he actually stands behind. This is not just satire. It's not
just a character. It's like his actual thing he's putting out
there is like his intelligent, well thought out, well thoughtout
opinion. surprise you to find out that this person is a VTuber
uh of course has uh engaged with uh
drawn material of children.
Okay.
And he is super pro-Israel. He apparently stalked uh Jaden Animation
for a while as well. I think a lot of people did that actually.
He is a
>> Hold on. The Zar Goof guy in Twitch chat just said something
crazy.
Yeah, I think it's okay for him to get banned. You can't make
a joke about his death the way he did. It's not about free speech.
It was just dumb of him to and to make this kind of joke. Does
every people that celebrated his death openly deserve $1,000
fine? Yes. No, they don't, Zarof. They don't deserve $1,000 fine.
There's a first amendment in the United States. He's laughing.
He is joking.
You're allowed to do that. I want you to pretend for two seconds
that Charlie Kirk that that bullet, okay, had a vial of estrogen
in it and Charlie Kirk was actually actively in the moments before
he bled out was transitioning. Okay, now is it funny? Cuz that's
that's usually a test for most people. If it was a trans person
who got shot, that'd be hilarious. It was a trans person who
killed themselves. That's hilarious. So, just think about Charlie
as if he was uh you know transitioning or something. Then it
becomes funny for everybody. I guess it's like I don't like people
I don't like people mocking his death either. Okay. I like I
personally just find it distasteful. I just find it distasteful.
But I also think you should be able to joke about whatever the
and not get banned from platforms. That didn't break the toos.
It didn't break any rules. It's just speech that offends the
current administration that's shown want like a a desire to go
after anybody who doesn't comport with like the things they want
politically, right? Anybody who's doing DEI, anybody supporting
Charlie, like people who are joking about Charlie Kirk, they'll
go after anyone. It's just bullying. It's just like actual authoritarianism
and I guess capitulating to that is just insane to me that the
idea that you capitulate is stupid. Yes,
you you should be able to make dark jokes without getting banned.
That's not even that dark a joke. Yes, but that's how it should
be handh handled. Wowi a speech that offends any normal person
the day of a people who enjoy the social contract with society.
Yes. And that should be something that people judge you for and
kind of like cut you out of polite conversation for, right? If
that's what you want to do, if you're just only trying to cause
outrage. Hold >> Just tip $5.
Rabbi Moshi here. Can you please stop doing that? You're taking
the stick a bit too far.
>> Can you stop doing that voice when you make fun of us?
It's gone a little bit too far. That wasn't even the voice, but
thank you, Gilbert Godfrieded. Yeah, sure. I should stop doing
the voice. Wait, when did I do the I didn't even do the voice
here. I didn't even do the voice today. I'll stop doing the voice
a little bit. Okay, I need to save it for special occasions.
Anyway, it wasn't even the worst joke Misk did. And the thing
that should upset you is that when you look at the difference
between the two jokes, okay,
the one that he actually got banned for
is significantly more tame than this one that comes after. This
one that comes after is like it's infinitely
infinitely worse in terms of being offensive, right? But this
is the one that he's gonna get banned for. No. What happened
was the the administration or even just Congress sent Twitch
a letter and now they're just like, "Oh, they're covering their
ass. They're just going to ban him for seven days." Anyway, it's
it's just it's a joke. It's just a cover your ass ban. It's stupid.
Nobody likes it. Everyone hates it. Anyway, uh let's uh let's
get back to the son stuff. Okay. who defended Dr. Disrespect
as well. >> He said, "Hi, here. I uniquely get from the
far right and the far left and I can say with 100% certainty,
I >> Why isn't he doing the voice? Why isn't he doing his
voice?" Okay. >> Wouldn't trust my life to a anti-semitic
universe Nick Fentes Grier named
for 42069 over a moderately leftist college student that goes
to overwhelmingly peaceful protest and celebrates Charlie Kirk's
assassination. That's how bad it is. Isn't this loser Canadian?
Yes, but apparently post October 7, he moved to Israel is what
people were saying. I am from Israel and this is my politic.
>> That's what I Sorry. That's a Why did he read the whole
thing in the voice? What the fus on? I trusted you to read it
in that I wanted that voice the whole time. You piece of [__]
>> Yeah. He said, "I hate moderate college campus leftists
who are anti-Israel so much
that I would rather entrust my life to a guy who one denies the
Holocaust and two demands more of it." Okay, that's I mean at
that point you have to understand like this is just a an out
andabout this is just an >> an out and about what? out
and about admission of your own mental illness.
>> So bad even his >> How did he go from that to
a destiny quip? What the [__] >> And also,
>> and speaking of the mentally ill, here's this guy. >> Speaking
of people who are aligned with one another, of course, there's
sexy,
listen, the the mental connection is forming, okay? Um he has
alongside Nooks Taku and numerous other like supposedly apolitical
slop tubers and Vtubers alike have found himself in a little
bit of trouble.
Okay. Uh-oh.
Here's how it is.
Some of you know this, many of you might not know this. Maybe
you saw like clip slam dunk compilations of Pestin uh for the
longest time and you don't fully understand what his worldview
is. Uh the easiest summarization of this of course is that he
just despises me with his entire soul and will go to any length
to try to either deplatform me or or um have me I mean he has
actually issued death threats against me in the past uh only
a couple months only a month ago as a matter of fact and he has
aligned >> they do they do start to blend together >> self
with
such as Sam Hyde when he was doing his whole like I'm going to
kill you Hassan [__] stick again another he has aligned
himself with Nick Fuentes in the past as well uh openly talking
about how he actually gave Nick Quentes a platform and how Nick
Fuentes who is also a and has talked about how he >> God
this guy is so obsessed with Destiny it's like can you just do
other content at some point what the [__] is >> he
wants to marry 16 so make up your own mind on that >> um
and is uh >> uh has gone gone on dates with cat boys and
things of that nature. So, uh, you know, another
he is a he's a a furry
kind of. I don't even understand how that works, but whatever.
Uh, just so you understand, the alignment is all over the place.
But um
Destiny himself also obviously is currently uh engaging in a
legal battle against
uh uh against his uh many numerous victims. Some of which he
filmed uh without consent, some of which he some of which he
did film with consent in acts, but he distributed that footage
to uh another minor that he was trying to actively have sex with.
>> that guy, he also hates me. Anyway, he has been
a a major advocate to try and deplatform me for years. >> Rean
Ruben donated $3. >> Why is Hassan dressed like he wants
a rooftop view of the next Destiny event? >> Is he dressed
like that?
He's just wearing a hoodie. What do you mean? >> He's wearing
a hoodie and a chain. I I don't think so. >> I think that
was meant to be a little edgy. I think that was uh that was a
rare miss. Okay, Reuben. Ruben, I I love you usually, but that's
a rare miss on that one.
major subreddits like live stream fails. >> Dude, Hassan
does have this speech. Hold on. Sugarlo says he has this speech
memorized. He does have the speech kind of memorized. It reminds
me of when I like shill for donations. Okay. He's like reading
the script. He's reading through the script on all of his haters.
It's funny stuff. >> And has been uh launching this conquest
against me. And despite the fact that he doesn't have like conquest
>> a massive audience or anything, he does have a very
loyal following.
a lot of jobless [__] who sit around and basically
make websites full of clips out of context. So if you see like
a lot of clips out of context flying around and you're like how
do I deal with this? Where is this coming from? A lot of that
has come from his community. And in the process of their deplatforming
initiatives over the course of the last two years post October
7, they built another website where uh they would try to uh get
me deplatformed
uh groups with call the other pro leopards. I'm going to wait
until he gets a little >> eating sex to >> There
we go. >> Oh, you know what? I actually pulled it >> Persuasive
capabilities.
>> I went a little too far forward. This is actually critical
context. I should never have doubted his on there. I started
skipping forward. Is all critical context. He's explaining how
Dan ran his whole campaign. Okay, ran this whole campaign for
months and months and months. And the ultimate the ultimate summation
of that campaign was to hurt Destiny's income more than he hurt
Hassan's income. He used Destiny's own audience to Destiny's
income. Isn't that crazy? People, I don't know if you guys know
this, but but Twitch ads are actually down. He did with Twitch
ads overall. Hassan, even if he could do political ads right
now, he wouldn't be making that much money. But but Dan managed
to go and get all of Destiny's clip channels demonetized.
Incredible stuff. This is like It turns out that when Turns out
that when Dan came back, he decided Destiny was a dangerous radical
that couldn't be trusted, that couldn't be that couldn't be allowed
to prosper. All right. And Dan came up with a clever clever 200
IQ play to plan out over time how he would use Destiny's audience
to destroy Destiny's income streams. Okay, incredible stuff.
This guy, I didn't give this guy enough credit. We got to hand
it to Dan Saltman, guys. We got to hand it to him. Okay. He managed
to kill Destiny's income streams worse than he did Hassan's and
he used Destiny's audience to do it.
>> That's talent. >> I like to call them the Apartheid
Defense League and numerous other Israel advocacy groups. They
align themselves with these advocacy groups to try and actively
deplatform me and many other pro Palestinian content creators.
They even went so far as to uh align with my former podcast co-host
Ethan Klein. You already know all of this stuff. But now
the leopards are eating
Pestiny's face because the very same groups that he and his podcast
co-host Dan Stalkman.
that now he's just he's just phoning it in now. What was that?
Dan Stalkman, >> also known as Dan Saltman.
>> Stalk. You mean Stalk. Dan Stockman >> are now
coming after Destiny. And there have been numerous updates on
this front and it has actually backfired on him
Um, I'm going to start off with uh this point here really quickly.
What? >> What is this? Hassan's haters are so stupid. This
website about Hassan's antise-mitism uses an image of a little
girl lighting lamps. This is the image has nothing to do with
Judaism. The makers of this website don't give a [__]
about anti-semitism. Yeah, [__] fund for Israel.
Fight back against the anti-semitism of [__] and
his friends. Make a donation. Was this one? Is this a uh this
must be a lingerie special right here? Right. >> In honor
of biker today.
Stock photo of a girl making rangolian decorating oil lamps for
Diwali. So if you if you want to understand like these >> all
brown people are the same to to anti-hassan people. Okay. Hassan
is here to defend all brown people. He can tell them apart.
They use this. They try to pretend this is like uh somebody in
Israel. Okay. It's not. It's not. That's somebody preparing for
Diwali. don't give a [__] about Judaism anyway. >> But
yeah, they made entire websites with dedicated clips out of context,
all this stuff. They they have been engaging in this deplatforming.
They are incredibly committed to this deplatforming initiative
uh and this in this smearing initiative for many many years and
it only actually expanded
uh after October 7. Okay. And they found a unique partner in
this with the Israel lobby. Uh, they found a unique partner in
the
>> hand of the gray. I don't know. Who are you? Who are
you talking to right now? We're having a great time over here.
Fant. Oh, you think I'm a traitor? Hold on. Traitor because I'm
watching Hassan stuff. I I hate Hassan's politics. I actually
do. I just laugh. Okay. You There's something charming about
Mr. Magcoo regardless of whether you think he's on a good mission
or not. Okay. And this guy goes he goes on stream every day.
He doesn't really do anything special. He watches the news. He
reacts to the news. He shuts the stream off. And his enemies
absolutely destroy themselves all over the internet. It's incredible
to watch. He has an
aura that seems to make certain people self-destruct. It's incredible
stuff. This with the Israel lobby because those guys are the
only ones crazy enough to continue uh trying to actively engage
in this deplatforming initiative because I'm one of the most
prominent critics of Israel on the internet and perhaps even
in North America.
And these guys have all the smoke. So in that in that endless
initiative,
Destiny's podcast co-host, >> you're obsessed, dude. Admit
it. Yes, I am obsessed. Yes, I am obsessed. I'm >> Dan
Saltman >> with watching Asan do nothing and win
>> Went to Washington DC on numerous occasions. Okay.
He did by his own admission.
He went to Washington DC and lobbyed Republican Congress members
because he realized that Republicans would be >> Oh god,
it's an old clip of Loner Box and Hassan.
Oh no.
What is this? Also, I need to use the bathroom real quick. I'll
be right back. But I'm listening. I'm listening. I'm listening.
I'll be right back. >> He did by his own admission.
He went to Washington DC and lobbyed Republican Congress members
because he realized that Republicans would be the only people
that were insane enough to try and engage in this deplatforming
initiative. Remember these people build themselves as liberals.
Okay, >> let's talk about you want to talk about the mission.
>> What's your what's your progress going forward with
Twitch?
>> I have congressional meetings set up. Okay, that's like
with more than one dude Republicans obviously
>> shifted uh
such a big >> um Oh, I guess it's when they're with multiple
congressmen and they it's like a factf finding mission for them
where they go and they um >> Oh my gosh. >> Oh, stop
the video. Sorry
right now. >> Okay. All right. So, a congressional video
is where not a congressional video, a congressional meeting is
where there's multiple of them >> and they're they have
their aids with them, their chiefs of staff with them. >> Yeah,
we had we had this conversation the other day and people are
like, "Oh, no. Dan Dan didn't really do anything here." It looks
like Dan did a lot. It looks like Dan was meeting with members
of Congress to try to get Hassan deplatformed.
It looks like he's kind of helped them build up all of their
factf finding for to like make this case at least at least with
regards to the Twitch platform. In fact, it kind of illuminates
why Twitch would be included in the factf finding mission for
the Charlie Kirk assassination, even though there's no evidence
Charlie Kirk has anything to do with it. I'm guessing they had
already been building this narrative with regards to Twitch before
this and they just took the the stuff they had and they're like,
"Oh, well, we'll just add some more people. We'll keep rolling
with the same thing, same
>> And then you have they're trying to find out like, "Okay,
explain this to us everything from start to finish." and they're
taking notes and then they're issuing subpoenas and [__]
like that after that based on the information of of what you
give. What would you like to
those very same Republican groups
of course got very mad at Destiny.
Read chat read which chat this chat. Hold on. This idiot is unlistable.
Lau truly cannot believe that this adult man has a voice that
sounds like that. Oh my god.
Picture and picture and picture and picture at Hassanabi. It's
what's the it's what for tea today. It's it's what's for tea
today.
Looks so uncomfortable with this creepoid. Oh, that's
okay. Because Destiny
never holds back
and has has no interest whatsoever. He wears it like a badge
of honor
uh to say some of the most unhinged things you've ever heard.
Okay.
And that he keeps the same energy when he's talking about uh
people to his left flank
and it obviously uh makes things a lot easier when he does that.
But he also keeps that same energy and and uh the interest in
dying on any hill no matter how unhinged it is when he's attacking
the Republicans.
So he started obviously on the Republicans in the aftermath of
the Charlie Kirk assassination, including saying things such
as uh you know the Republicans need to have be in an environment
of fear. Some of the things he actually said that people are
yelling at him over weren't even unreasonable. I'm not sure if
Hassan is trying to blame myself or for this. The anti-semitism
defense. Uhoh. Uhoh.
Not good. I think Hassan Hassan's just blamed me because I'm
I've not talked, emailed, DM'd, or had any communication with
anyone involved with this directly or indirectly. They chose
to investigate Twitch all by themselves. I had no idea this was
coming or even in the work until it hit the works until it hit
the news. Oh, so what?
Oh, this is actually bad. Why does Dan do this? Why does Dan
go live and talk about how he has meetings with multiple Congress
people to investigate Twitch and Hassan extremism,
right? And then he's like, "Guys, I had no idea." No. What he's
trying to say is, "I had no idea this was happening." But what
he means is, "Well, I had conversations about something totally
different." Right? That's what he's trying to say. But it's not
totally different. It's not totally different, and nobody would
really perceive it as totally different. It's obvious that it's
the exact same argument. Left-leaning content creators are radicalizing
people on these platforms. It is literally the same argument.
And there is no evidence that that Tyler Robinson was radicalized
by Twitch. So, it's very clear why Twitch was included in this
to me. But it's interesting. It's very funny that he could have
that clip with loader box and then also say this. >> Well,
we're tal he talked about how the president should be lowering
the temperature. I agree with that. But of course, Republicans
don't agree with that. So, they've been coming after him and
using at least some of the clips
uh many of it acrewed over his almost like what 15-year broadcasting
career against him now. But now Dan has backed away. Even though
even though he kept repeatedly
making calls for my deplatforming over and over again over every
single day over the past year, past two years as a matter of
fact, tagging Leo Terrell, tagging Laura Loomer, tagging uh prominent
Republicans in Congress over and over. >> Is it really
that? I don't know if it's that long. I think it's a year. The
past year. I think it's the past year. way >> where he
said Dan Salman just told the Son [__] he played
no role in lobbying Congress to enact censorship on Twitch. Here's
Dan Salman talking to Lonerbox about how he set up a meeting
with multiple Republican congressmen to talk about cracking down
on Twitch. I am not sure if Aan is trying to blame myself or
in parenthesis for this. But for clarity sake, I have not talked,
emailed, DM'd or had any communication with anyone involved with
this directly or indirectly. They chose to investigate Twitch
all by themselves. I had no idea this was coming or even in the
works until it hit the news. Here he is crying that the clip
was from 10 months ago. But here's where he explains his motivation
and takes credit for creating the circumstances for the crackdown.
I may have pushed this snowball to the top of the hill, but the
avalanche is out of my hands. Now, what's really interesting
about this statement is that this has happened in the past as
well, like when Twitch banned the word Zionist.
That was also his
at his direction. That is something that he petitioned for. Oh,
so he literally says, "I pushed the snowball to the top of the
hill." Like the thing that got everybody's attention is Elon
Musk going in on this. Teone and Dan got Elon Musk's attention.
They were showing him clips of Assan, right? That is something
that he campaigned for. That is something that he worked alongside
the ADL with to accomplish. And when it happened and people got
mad, he said, "Oh, I didn't do this.
I I don't even think it's a good idea." He says, "It's Dan's
fault Trump banned Miskf." Uh, well, Trump didn't ban Miskf.
is probably actually Dan's fault that Msk got banned. I think
Msk should blame Dan. I think he should blame Dan is so No, not
quite. But uh absolutely that's a part of the creating this environment,
right? I just I don't know with Miskf specifically. I don't know
how much there is. I think there's more of a focus on the politics
group on Twitch. But Miskf caught in the crossfire again. >> I
have no This is on 2025 9:15. Okay. I have no control over it.
Meow. But the avalanche is out of my hands. Gulog, I may have
pushed this snowball to the >> You're reading it in the
reverse order. Come on, man. Come on, man. It doesn't even What
you're reading doesn't even make sense.
>> I laughing. I just Okay. I have no control over it.
Meow. But the avalanches out of my hands. Gulog. I may have pushed
this snowball to the top.
I laughing. I just woke up. Lol. My single issue TTD, which means
total Twitch death. I'm a single issue voter. I can focus on
my one thing. Other people are focused on very important things.
Kaiser one enemy. >> What are he learned that term from
>> me at the time? I have a different view on effectiveness
than destiny on this. Look, I understand the push back. The more
we ignore it, the more we lose. My plan is an accelerationist
view that the faster the mainstream media can eject far-left
radicals, the stronger and better the Democratic party will be
to win. And if our shoelaces are tied together, we are. >> By
the way, this is not even even if Dan had this belief, you couldn't
trust what he says here, right? That's the problem. Like even
if Dan really believed this, he will just lie and say that that's
his goal to Hassan, right? Because that's really his goal. His
goal is to over Hassan and Dan Clansancy. It's like a personal
vendetta that he is trying to get all these people like galvanized
around him for. It's purely personal. And any other any other
like purported motive is pretty easily discarded cuz he's had
like a hundred different motives for undertaking this mission
throughout the entire time he's been doing it. He just shifts
the motive to whatever is convenient in the moment because he
wants to be a from the start, but it's like we need to get dressed
and put our boxing gloves to do it and I want to fight it. I'm
not rworded. I understand who's in charge right now and what's
going on. Yes, this person is uh also 50 years old. I know I
read it in the wrong order. It actually is bottomed up. Okay,
this is in the private chat room that they have uh that is um
DGG.
They're probably watching right now. As a matter of fact, they
watch my stream probably more than they watch Destiny's own stream,
as a matter of fact. All right. Any >> that might be true.
That actually Hold on. That might that could be true. >> that's
possible.
>> Here he is also trying to reveal
uh you know, also trying to again defend his position after actively
agitating and actively demanding that this happens.
Okay, here he is. I want to explain why I'm particularly focused
on Twitch and its promotion of extremist left voices, even as
other pressing issues demand attention. While there is substantial
work being done to combat fascist rhetoric from the far right,
where is that, by the way? Where is that happening? I haven't
seen it. I'm doing is that is that like uh where is it that evidence
is that in like Candace Owens, Ian Carol, Tucker Carlson, and
Nick Fentes totally monopolizing all online content creation
for right-wingers? Is that in them getting a 100,000 viewers
each like concurrent all the time? Is Is that where it's evident?
Where is this evident at all? What?
That's insane. That's an insane thing to say.
In fact, I want to say that I made this argument back then that
like, okay, Hassan's bad. Okay, Hassan is bad. But pretending
he's like worse for mainstream politics in the United States
than Nick Fentes is insane. It's an insane thing to do. and you're
not focused on this guy who's growing massively, right?
You're taking all of your attention. You're taking it off of
Nick Fuentes. You're putting on Hassan. And not only that, you're
defending it. You're saying, you know what? It actually makes
sense for us to focus on Hassan instead of Nick Fuentes. If you
are somebody who believes in liberalism, if you're somebody who
believes in multiculturalism,
like you you cannot have that position. It's just insane.
You're just lying to everybody if you say you have those positions
and also think Nick Fuentes is inherently more harmful to political
discourse than Hassan is >> doing that you're focused on
me. Uh I believe that extremist leftist tankies and Marxist pose
one of the greatest threats to the Democratic party's ability
to unify and govern effectively. Their influence though not back
Hello.
>> What is this? This is Matt Edelt with the 10 gifted.
Let's go. That's uh what are we that's 10 that's >> two
more hours on the stream. Thank you very much Matt. Appreciate
it, buddy.
>> Matt NLT here for the socialist content. Okay. Somebody
who doesn't agree with me in politics almost in any way, but
does support the stream because I am willing to say maybe Hassan's
not quite as bad as an actual
I I know it's it's crazy to say, okay, but possibly Hassan might
be a little bit less bad than an I know. It's I know. I know.
I know. I I've been radicalized, guys. have been radicalized
by the left wing to to have these crazy opinions. I don't know
what to tell you.
>> Is good. >> He's not I don't know if you heard
that. Somebody said Hassan is good. A voice over my shoulder.
Not right. Not correct. All right, let's continue on. >> Back
by significant. >> Looks like he's about to
read the rest of this.
>> Uh I believe that extremist leftist, tankies, and Marxist
pose one of the greatest threats of the Democratic party's ability
to unify and govern effectively. Their influence, though not
backed by significant Democratic power, has been corrosive, alienating
average citizens by prioritizing ideology over practical solutions.
What's ironic is it's actually the opposite. It's the Democratic
party's inability to actually uh uh lean into their left flank
and and boldly and proudly proclaim progressive policy positions
that would be real prescriptions to the issues that average Americans
feel that has caused them to lose. The Lis Cheney dynamic is
the perfect example of this. You run around with Liz Cheney,
you lose the [__] election. It's that simple. So,
he is I don't even think that he is being uh uh
I'm going to entertain charitably that Dan Saltman literally
believes this. Okay.
Mistake, but okay, that's fine. I do tend to think like the best
way to approach anything when you don't know for sure is just
to take somebody at face value and work out from there. I don't
think you should ever work if you're like unfamiliar with somebody,
you should never work from the place where you just assume they're
like in working in bad faith all the time. It's just better not
to interact with anything they're doing, right? If you're going
to not know somebody's past at all and just say that they seem
like they're lying or that you think they're only operating in
bad faith, it's like just don't interact, right? That's that's
how you got to treat it. You just don't don't interact in that
case. So, I like I like when somebody says, "Yeah, I'll just
I'll take this at face value for now. I'm going to entertain
the notion that he actually subscribes to this policy, this principle,
the notion that like it's actually the tankies that are the reason
for the Democratic party's demise, right? Maybe he genuinely
believes it. Maybe he genuinely believes it. Okay. The irony,
of course, is that it's wrong.
And the past election has proven this to be wrong. Zoram Mani
has proven this to be wrong over and over. >> I don't know.
I don't know if I don't know if it's proven to be wrong. I don't
know. I think there's
arguments on both sides to embracing the left wing versus embracing
the center. Like obviously people on like young people are moving
more towards like this this more progressive platform. Uh people
in general moving to a more populist platform. There's some intersection
there that is kind of overlapping with socialism in a way that
you probably have to engage with. But there is still a lot of
people who are undecided like centrist voters who is still probably
the most effective block to go after. Uh, I just don't think
you do that by going and campaigning with Liz Cheney, as he said.
I don't think there's anybody who's excited. There wasn't a single
person who went like, "Oh, they're campaigning with Liz." That's
awesome. I love that. I now I really want to vote for these guys.
Like, literally everybody under the sun hates Liz Cheney. Like,
could you dig up corpse and go campaigning with them? I'm pretty
sure nobody wants to see you talk to Liz Cheney. Nobody wants
Liz Cheney involved. Nobody cares. And over again, this is the
reason why the party has failed. This is the reason why there's
so much discontent at a time when the Democratic party as the
left flank as the counterbalance to the growing discontent against
the Republicans that are in charge should be super popular but
they're not. And it's because of this like centrist presentation
that they're not. >> Uh hold on. Porter Beller says appealing
to the center lost in 16 and 24 and only won in 20 because of
COVID. No, they didn't appeal to the center. Okay. I should say
appeal to the center and appeal to identity. Okay, that's what
you need to do. Appeal to the center and appeal to identity.
Okay, when you have the better platform, all you do is appeal
to the same identity groups as your opponent and you win automatically
as the Democrats. We have way better policies. People take us
way more seriously. All we need to do is is literally appeal
to the same identity. White man. Get a white man. Run a white
man and you win all three of those elections. Well, you don't
win all three because not Trump. It's not Trump running against
you in each one, but Hillary Clinton, if you have uh if you have
Joe Biden in that Hillary Clinton 2016 election, landslide Democrat
victory. Not even close. Not even remotely close. Okay. I'm sorry,
but you just have to you got to grapple with reality sometimes,
but people don't want to grapple with reality. So, yeah, it's
rough. Okay. Yes, I'm saying I agree with you, Portella, that
they ran to the center. I think focusing on running to the center
in terms of policy is here or there. Okay. I think you just have
to go. You just have to appeal to the same identity. That's how
you beat Donald Trump every time. People don't like Donald Trump.
There are a lot of centrist people who don't like Donald Trump.
They just see you running like Hillary Clinton, the least likable
person on planet Earth, and they're like, "Yeah, that." Even
though, okay, I will admit that Hillary had some points, okay?
I I hate Hillary Clinton far less than I did, but that's because
I'm enlightened. Not everybody's enlightened. The average voter
is not enlightened. The average voter is not I'm with her pled
yet. Okay? They'll get there eventually, but nobody's there yet.
It turns out you actually, it turns out that you can either eat
the bugs because the globalists are forcing it down your throat
and you have a a great life otherwise, or you can eat the bugs
because they've nucle they've like gone to nuclear winter. Bugs
are the only thing left for protein in any way and the planet's
destroyed, right? It's like, listen, there are there are different
circumstances you could be eating the bugs in. You're going to
be eating the bugs with people like Trump in any case, okay?
It's gonna [__] up everything. You're going to be
eating the bugs, but you're also not going to have television
shows to make it feel better. Okay, just let the globalist win
some. I don't know. I'm just I'm ranting about nothing. >> For
Democrats to successfully unify and fight against the rising
giving you my skitso thoughts, okay, those are my skitso thoughts.
>> Out of right-wing extremism, we cannot afford to have
our own efforts sabotaged by agitators with >> you just
need a charismatic candidate. Obama was black and that didn't
stop him. Uh, one, Obama was a once in a like generation charismatic
candidate who could take anything and spin it positively for
himself. And two, he was the first black man to run for president
and got a huge built-in vote because of that. Not really a good
he can't go, hey, give me a unicorn. I need I need to run another
unicorn. The only way we can win is with a unicorn. That's not
true. In our ranks, these individuals are not interested in compromise
or success. They seek only to see the party fail so they can
smuggly say, "I told you so." If that was the case, I would not
be actively working within the uh Democratic party in ways that
are infinitely more meaningful than whatever the this is doing
where he aligns with Republicans to deplatform me. I'm the one
who's going out and and trying to get people to door knock for
Democrats. He's the who is again aligning with Republicans to
deplatform me. >> Has Sassan done a lot of doornocking?
I'm I'm unaware of his doornocking campaigns, but maybe these
guys love talking about how much work they want to put in to
fight the far right, but then they align with the far right.
How the [__] does that work? Twitch plays a uniquely
harmful role in this dynamic, unlike platforms such as Twitter
or Reddit where multiple viewpoints can circulate. Twitch disproportionately
amplifies far-left voices while suppressing others. This is also
incorrect. And this is the reason why they have coped themselves
into aligning with Asmin Gold and even Tech Tone.
Okay, that's it. They know that there are far-right voices on
Twitch. Okay, they know that. Actually, as a matter of fact,
they have designed it so that there is at less
had a Msk had a good one. Okay, Misk threw up a good one. Let's
check it out. Hold on a second. Quick Msk update. He's in high
spirits. He's got the support of one of America's most powerful
people. Okay, why is this not loading? Hello, my internet. Hello.
What's going on? Okay, I'll open another tab. What's going on
here? Is my stream still alive? It is. What's going on? Why can't
I go to anything? Okay. X is going to load. Oh, they all went.
Okay.
The commentary off. This commentary offers a clear powerful statement
of why freedom of speech is at the heart of democracy must be
defended. Whether the speaker is Charlie Kirk or Jimmy Kimmel,
MAGA supporters or MAGA opponents. Appreciate the support. Obama.
Let's go.
>> You reckon just tip 1099?
Despite everything, Kirk failed to make a generation of good
youth debaters. You need to work a bit harder to make people
understand having principles.
>> Uh, I think he probably did, but it's a bit of a bit
of a dodgy time to make that point. Anyway, we'll continue. >> At least
a lot of pressure on Twitch to amplify right-wing voices. Asmin
Gold hasn't been streaming because his dad recently passed away.
But Asmin Gold until he stopped streaming for the past month
or so was literally the biggest political commentator in North
America and he very much had a right-wing position. He was pro
Trump. Yes. Rest in rest in peace to Asmin dad. Of course, Twitch
disproportionately amplifies far
>> Dude, I had somebody come in yesterday and he's here
a decent amount. So, I'm not even going to call the person out
direct. I'm not going to say the per the name, but like it was
like I'm I'm waiting for you guys to make fun of Asmin Gold's
dad passing away. It's like, bro, everybody loved Asmin Gold's
dad. What are you talking about? That was like the highlight
of Asmin Gold's streams for anybody who was like left of center
politically. Was Asmin Gold's dad coming on and being like, you're
kind of lying right now. And actually, here's why Trump's bad.
Did you see Hassan pulled up Asmin dad's chat logs? No, I did
not see that. But >> they led the troubling incident such
as >> That was today. That was yesterday. >> Blocking
Israeli signups for a year. He still keeps bringing up this false
fake
and hosting anti-semitic content at official events. He won't
say what it is. He's talking about the hot the the Sabra hummus
tier list. That's what he >> hold on. Sorry. The asmin
dad logs might have been today. >> Saying is an anti-semitic
event, an anti-semitic incident. Of course, he'll never openly
say that because if he were to openly reveal that that's what
he was uh was pushing for, then people are going to be like,
"That's a laughable notion. Shut the up." The platform's influence
among young audiences makes this even more concerning, especially
given the co stated goal of reaching children as young as eight.
When extremist voices are elevated for clicks and moderate voices
are ignored, it creates a deeply unhealthy and dangerous environment.
This is the same dumbass
right-wing uh perspective, which is why are our voices not popular?
Why is Hutch not a more popular voice?
Okay.
I don't know, but I think you should probably think about that
on your own time instead of >> how is Hutch not a more
popular voice >> actively trying to silence descent against
that position.
Okay,
>> maybe it's because he's wrong all the
>> No, it can't be that. No, it hold on. Wait. Has Han
considered
Hasan considered that Hutch is our boy? Has Hassan considered
that? Hutch is our boy. What are you doing? What is he
>> And people go, I don't really want to take my notes
from a guy who's wrong all the time. I respect and trust the
ongoing efforts to combat the far right. He doesn't. But I believe
it's equally critical to address harm caused by oursized extremists.
If we do not remove these voices from positions of influence
within the Democratic party, we will severely undermine our ability
to tackle larger political challenges. We cannot go into 2026
with campaign candidates campaigning on unrealistic policies
like forced gun buybacks or universal healthcare. Universal
>> Okay, gun buybacks probably are unpopular. Okay, but
universal is anybody really saying universal healthcare is unpopular?
>> Universal healthcare is an unrealistic policy. These
unattainable goals only solidify our losses. At the moment, the
right is targeting far-left influencer. If their efforts render
these extremist policy toxic, politically toxic, I see no reason
to intervene. As Napoleon famously said, never interrupt when
your enemy when he is making a mistake. Every day puff pieces
are published celebrating these extremists and pushing them as
the left Joe Rogan. This is a mistake. They should form their
own party and leave Democrats free to focus on achievable pragmatic
goals. We need social democrats, not democratic socialists. He
literally just said universal healthcare is an unrealistic policy,
then claims that he's a social democrat. What the are you talking
about? It's the most pivotal achievement of social democracy
and it exists everywhere. Anyway, >> two legs. I do know
what you're talking about. And gross. >> Half the time
it feels as though we are arguing with morons. And that is because
we are. Okay. I'm starting to suspect he isn't very smart. He's
not. Exactly. He does this every time. His campaign to bash the
left backfires and inadvertently furthers right-wing causes.
He pretends that he had nothing to do with it and cries that
people are blaming him. Yes, they have done this over and over
again. whenever their active deplatforming initiatives actually
successfully roll back some semblance of free speech. >> It's
funny. It's just funny to me how this is from November 15th and
free discourse and it not exactly. They have done he does this
every time his campaign left back to actually successfully roll
back some semblance of free speech. I just like that this guy
first started posting about Dan in November though free discourse
and it actually harms left creators and even liberal creators
as a matter of fact like queer creators and whatnot. He turns
around and goes, "Oh, I didn't want this to happen." You did.
What policies does he want? What the [__] are his
politics? His policies are just anti-left. His goals are just
anti-left. That's all it is. Okay. And for the record, for the
record, this is what actually ended up happening. So,
okay, I knew he was going to get there eventually. All right,
I knew he was working his way up there. Eventually, over time,
he was going to make it. And and say what we all know to be true,
okay, is that the ultimate like the ultimate result, the ultimate
win for Dan was actually getting Destiny's nuked. A lot of Destiny's
old clips and new clips about Charlie Kirk and about Donald Trump
and about political violence
was then highlighted by the same Republicans that Dan Alman had
aligned himself with to try to deplatform me. Okay.
And lo and behold,
those guys obviously got those guys obviously got
excited to attack Destiny as well because they see him as a liberal
voice. I mean, he's been on CNN, right, as like the the heel
to Charlie Kirk, right? They even went so far as to bring his
name up in the Would Dan ever talk to Hassan?
Dan used to do a D and D campaign with Hassan where Dan was an
like a veently anti-Semitic caricature of a well verently anti-Semitic
caricature. I was going to say of a person, but that kind of
plays itself out or kind of explains itself. All right.
He didn't mind. Okay. He didn't mind being he didn't mind doing
that with Han back in the day. Congressional record. Yes. Oh,
also the the let the streets run red with their blood. Those
mother kill them. That clip from Hassan, that's him talking to
Dan claiming Destiny a week prior to Charlie K's assassination
said Charlie Kirk is a demonic entity. And even it was such an
idiotic thing to put in the congressional record that even Jim
Jordan turned around and said, "Well, tough. That's the first
amendment." Which is true by the way. It is such a stupid take.
It blows my mind that people would get mad at that. Like, what
are you talking about? We can't say that our political opposition
is bad. What What are we doing here? Which is of course the goal
of the Republican party, the goal of a fascist administration.
Oh, sorry. Jim Jordan didn't say that. Jerry Nadler did. Sorry.
I thought it was Jim Jordan that said that. But in any case,
in any case, in that environment, in this misinformation environment,
Destiny, who is an who is a rapacious troll, turned around and
uh brought up his Okay. Rapacious. Really? Rapacious.
Rapacious.
Rapacious like aggressively or greedy or grasping troll. Okay.
Are we pulling out the thesaurus now? Rapacious landlords. Is
this just a synonym for grappler? Grasping, greedy, avaricious,
inquisitive, covetous. This guy's This guy's got a anti-semitic
thesaurus right now. What the is former Twitch ban? He would
he was banned from Twitch a very long time ago in like 2022 or
something. Okay, he posted that and said, "Oh no, your cancellation
efforts have actually harmed me. I've lost my platform on Twitch."
And what's ironic is that because Republicans are >> Okay,
so this is funny and it's something people are pointing out.
It's uh it's very very funny that I think Destiny's prank on
Fox News where he convinced them that he actually got banned
and then a whole bunch of DJers flood into all the comments going,
"You stupid mother, he's been banned
Is that not like pretty clearly what would have led to somebody
going to his YouTube channel? Oh, where wait where does this
guy stream? You morons didn't get him. He He owned you. He owned
you, dude. Well, hold on. Um,
they might have actually wanted or sorry, Destiny might have
actually wanted them to play along and like not point it out,
right? Just think they won, but all the DJs flood the comments
and they go, "He actually owned you. You just did misinformation.
That's like the biggest sin. You just did misinformation." And
they're like, "Oh, well, let's try to correct that. Let's try
to make it true that he lost a bunch of his income."
Not good. Not great. so stupid. They thought that was a major
victory without actually fact-checking whether or not he was
actually banned. And that was even talked about on Fox News.
Jesse Waters did a news hit on it. Said this
far-left violent man got banned off Twitch. But I suspect because
that happened and because there was a lot more pressure, it seems
that Destiny was actually demonetized on YouTube. Okay. So what
ended up happening is what he was trying to do to me for years
and years and years had >> I think okay if we have a pool
on when this comes back I'd take like three days probably if
we started a pool on it I think I go three days sorry just when
when Destie gets like his back >> I I think he gets it
back within 3 days not that he like deserves it back like
not really it's just like I'm I'm guessing 3 days tops to get
remonetized on Twitch is this the price is right rules Oh, it's
a pool. So, whoever's closest, you you can go over. Um,
so Dan got Destiny demonetized. Well, you could argue this. You
could argue that Dan's campaign led to the effects of Destiny
being demonetized, right? Somebody's been seing this whole thing
about leftist radicalizing people to violence for months and
months and months. It's like one guy behind it. Own allies. as
a matter of fact, partially because of his own [__]
allies and their endless interest in aligning with [__]
fascist Republicans who want to take out any kind of opposition,
any kind of discontent. No matter you think Dashi will get remonetized,
why? Um
because I think that
YouTube is going to sense the winds and I don't think they're
going to actually or you know maybe not maybe not 3 days but
within like a month I feel like I feel like there'll be some
court case that start gets like super fasttracked and people
will see you're not allowed to like actually threaten any of
these platforms really. You're not allowed to do it. I think
eventually somebody will stand up business there I think. Didn't
Fresh and Fit get remonetized? Uh they're not monetized now if
they did get remonetized. Um, I don't think has pearly things
ever been remonetized.
Pearly things I but like I think that's about the the level of
discourse that happens on Destiny stream a lot of the time is
like pearly things level. So, no they didn't. I think you have
a good chance right off the bat. I think it's more in line with
the Dr. Disrespect stuff. I think it's like the Dr. Disrespect
demonetization.
We like let let things like fade off for a little while. We let
it fade. we let things cool and then
yeah then we'll remonetize this person because they didn't really
like I think you can argue Destiny's breaking toos but they just
don't punish that aggressively a lot of the time no matter how
liberal no matter how moderate those voices may be they ended
up targeting him successfully and taking away
his uh one of his revenue streams that is where we're at and
that's the reason why Dan Saltman has been talking about how
he had nothing to do with this he said the Yaz2020 27. Trump
is on life support but still wheeled out for TV appearances.
The US has been in civil war for 16 months. Food is scarce. Medicine
and ammunition hard to come by. Dan is a tweeting about Hassan.
>> Hassan's Hassan's dyslexia is hilarious sometimes. Okay.
Hassan's dyslexia is funnier than anybody
any other streamer. All right. >> He's even on Dan. The
only other community we had a bridge with torches it because
Ethan's a spineless hack as well. Just such pathetic state of
affairs of everyone over here. Adam Mockler is the only exception
to what I said. Everyone else is a [__] loser. See
you all in the camps. He also revealed that he no longer wants
to do politics, which he's not going to do. Destiny announces
he's retiring from politics and focusing on gaming. >> Hold
on. This is also This is also really funny. >> He says,
"Look at how they stick together. Unreal. I think I might do
this event and retire to gaming 6 months for six months or indefinitely.
I think >> that will never happen. Desi will lose the attention
he gets if he goes to gaming. He he will never do that. He will
never do that. He'll never accept like this loss. It's it's one
thing that like you kind of can't take away from him, right?
Is
he will out of spite do like a thing people say he can't do for
like months and months and months and like try to make it work.
Like he will spitefully grind anything to to make it back, right?
No, no, no. He He was not going to play League again. Trust me.
But I'm telling you that I don't think he'll ever stop. I think
he will. He'll run this into the ground. I I believe I don't
think he'll ever retire. He'll run it into the ground trying
to make a like a comeback over and over and over again. I don't
think he's ever done. I don't think it's ever over. I think he'll
try forever. I don't even think he'll like fail necessarily,
right? He I would like to see that, but I don't think he'll necessarily
fail. I think he'll just keep going forever. I think even if
he had like a 500 viewer stream, I think he would I think he
would still be streaming like a lot with like a 500 or,000 viewer
stream like all the time. think it should just be a conservative
fascist government. People like Hutch, Pisco, CNN, etc. can do
their thing. It's just way too many with zero. This is a weird
grouping, isn't it? Isn't this a weird grouping? Hutch, Pisco,
CNN. What? Like, who are your enemies at this point? It's just
too many with zero spine
spine. There is no point. >> How is How is Pisco like CNN?
Maybe I could see Hutch a little bit, but also is CNN like an
insult now >> to which this uh celebrated apparently called
DG Snark. I didn't even know that there was a snark for DGG.
>> Uh where's I don't have stop the cap on my I don't have
stop the cap on my soundboard. Okay, I don't have it, but stop
the cap. Stop. Oh. Oh, there's a subreddit called DG Snark. I'm
very unaware of this. I don't know that sign. You're the most
informal. Okay, it's just a 0% chance. Come on, Hassan. Don't
lie to me like that. What are you doing? Come on, man. I thought
we were friends and you're just going to lie to me like that.
What? A DG snark, you say? Like they snark on DGG and Destiny
there? Like uh Oh, kind of like H3. Oh, like the like the Ethan
thing. Oh, I wow.
This first I'm hearing of it
of of former uh Destiny fans. Destiny has been harassing and
stalking Assan and other pro Palestinian streamers for two years
to bring attention to himself. Now he's received 1% of the vitriol
they have received and immediately gives up and succumbs to fascism.
This is liberalism in a nutshell.
Yeah. I mean, I don't think he's succumbing to fascism. I think
he's succumbing to narcissism. Okay. It's a different sism,
different one. Okay. Narcissism, fascism. There's a lot of overlaps
that people would point out, but I I think he's just like, why
didn't they back me up? Why did all these people back me up when
I decided we needed to make a stand here? Don't they know that
I'm the one who makes the choice? I'm the one who decides that
this is where we say violence is okay. I It's me. I'm It's me.
It's me. I'm the one. I'm the one who gets to Yeah. No. Nobody
else wants to Nobody else is like, "Yeah, this random lone gunman
who shot down Charlie Kirk." That's where we draw the line. That's
where we say this is our stand. Actually, no. That's a hill to
die on. That's the dumbest hill to die on. That's the most optically
cancerous hill to die on right now. Why would you pick that?
Even if these people liked you and wanted to stand with you,
I don't think they could. Arodite and Arodite and soy pill want
to stand with the guys so badly and they still feel like they're
their long-term career prospects are like a requirement is pushing
back against him in public. Not that they do it effectively or
anything like that. I'm just saying they they think like they
have to do that, right? Look, >> Vos would approve. Vos
was defending >> They're going, "Oh no.
Oh no. Is you going to watch the whole 6-inute Alex Jones video?
Shocking video. Watch leftist mouthpiece. Destiny. Brag about
planning to murder a family. Blame President Trump for Charlie
Kirk's assassination. Call for more conservative deaths at rallies.
Wish for the death of Devon Nunees. How does Alex Jones not include
the child stuff in here? That should be in all of these videos
if you're doing them. But hey, that's just my humble snarking
opinion, okay? That that's a thing you should start including
for more people. >> Alex Jones is doing full clip compilations
about Destiny. Shocking violence. Watch leftist mount peace destiny.
Brag about planning to murder a family. Blame President Trump
for Charlie Kirk's assassination. Call for more conservative
deaths at rallies. Wish for the death of Deon Nunees. We are
live breaking it down. Oh, Casey Tron's in the comments. Expose
the truth, please, Alex. That's barely even the tip of the iceberg.
It's also believed that one of his gay lovers was Nick Fuentes,
who was making death threats towards Charlie Kirk for years.
Oh, Casey Tron, not helping here. Okay, Alex, don't want that
Fuentes smoke. You don't want that groper smoke. Okay, that's
that's not what he wants at all. I just clicked off of what we're
doing. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. We We click it back. We click it back. We click it.
Here we go. >> It's before and after the the takeover of
the fascists.
>> Okay. Unreal. I think >> Let me run it up to where
we were. >> Pelosi is a communist. >> You guys are
stupid. If you're a liberal and if you hate the Republican party,
>> okay, if you hate what the Republicans are doing to
this country, if you hate the erosion of civil liberties,
>> any moment that you spend attacking your left flank,
many of which are actually out in the streets before and after
the the takeover of the fascists,
is idiotic. It's unproductive.
And there needs to be a recognition that maybe you were wrong.
Okay, maybe you were wrong. The highlighting of your left flank
as the real scary enemies that are at Did we see this? I think
soy pill is a plant wolf in sheep's clothing.
What? Dude, you do love when when people get significantly more
over time unhinged and kind of lose it. Also, I think that message
got swallowed by kick, but Oh, here we go. Dude, Twitter is on
one right now. Okay, what is this? Seriously, after all that
he's has been going on, why push the this issue to drive further
division on the left? Why go through the trouble of traveling
to rehash this? Plant might not be the right word. May probably
more of a wolf in sheep's clothing. Even leftists like Bosch
aren't this unhinged. Soy fed poster pill.
Uh-huh. Yeah. Hey Destiny, I think it's kind of weird that you're
like refusing to disavow violence and really like bad optically
for the rest of us. And like I'm usually on your side, but act
it seems like really dumb to do it right now. And and they're
all like, "Oh god, soy fed poster pill." I feel like it's a virtue
signal. The KF/Jock posters that he doesn't stand with agree
with Destiny. So they don't do harass swat him like they did
to Hutch Pisco I. Dude, I'm sorry.
I am responsible for none of this. Okay, this is insane to try
to blame me or try to to amplify that I'm to blame for any of
this. So insane. People just lie. Just go on the internet and
tell lies. Everyone who criticizes Destiny about anything is
unhinged trader scum. Well, I just hope it like starts to come
together for people, right? You're embarrassing me. I have to
clean up your What the actual is wrong with this loser? The intelligent
liberals can't even unite at their own event. I am losing tons
of opium. Uh I don't know if that's true, Dinglingus. I This
person says that. I have no idea. Uh there's a reason unfortunately
aside from the drama that everyone has largely carved out their
own areas of influence away from the community. It's because
Desi is insanely controversial and Soy by engaging in his project
with other major figures probably has to be confronted by with
some of the things Desi is saying. Now that's just speculation.
Yes, obviously. Yeah, you have to explain why you're working
with this guy when he says insane when he does insane.
Trump was so What about Trump though? That's literally the only
response. What about Trump? Why can't Destiny just be the Why
can't you just let Destiny do what Trump does? Why can't you
just let Destiny be the guy who runs the cult on the left? We
just want leftist Trump. That's all we want, guys. Can we Can
we just have leftist Trump and it be Destiny?
Just let him do whatever he wants. Let him get away with anything.
That's the rules, guys. That's the only way we could save democracy.
Just let him do whatever he wants. Let him break law. Let him
do anything, man. Come on. Come on, guys. Isn't that the way
we need it? No. None of us want that. None of us None of the
rest of us want that. Okay. Anyway, Trump was so controversial
that his current vice president compared him to I'm not saying
there may be uh there I'm not saying there may be pramatic way
pragmatic ways to distance yourself from Dman, but this is very
intentional to undermine his valid point. He doesn't have a valid
point. There's everybody else is correct here. Destiny is the
ones who who's wrong. They don't understand it. Let him sure
see Sam. Let him Yeah, it's the it the only explanation I can
find that is just the game. They feel destiny is going downhills.
They ought to use it for their benefit. If they would really
care, private conversations.
How dare you say this about him in public. How dare you? How
dare you? How dare you? Soy Pill was right, and I don't think
he is. Then Destiny's rhetoric would lead to more violence and
no benefit. It would be stupid for him to not fight on this point
if he believes his argument. Oh, somebody's slightly sane. Okay.
Do they actually believe that if Destiny raped someone, everyone
would just abide by that and ignore that? I can't believe they
actually think this is true. Well, they would probably say no
for that one, right? Even though it is true, right?
Even though Benny, you've seen the Mantis tweet, right? You've
seen the Mantis tweet. Do I have to We've seen the Mantis tweet.
Yes. This is a This is an upvoted post in the Daliban. How mad
will the haters be when this drama blows over and people still
prefer Destiny to them? Not even can do it. It's like like this
is this is an actual sentiment that exists. It's real. It's it's
real. This is the This is the level these people are at. Where
were we? Here. Here. Okay, we'll get back to Listen, we're adding
to Hassan snarking a little bit. Okay, we'll get back to the
Hassan snarking just in a second.
Destiny should have asked soy pill why he isn't vegan. Hey, Destiny,
I think you could just like you you could probably just disavow
the violence to Charlie Kirk and then talk about how the right
is really unhinged and Trump's like calling for violence himself.
No, no, actually, soy Pill, have you considered that you're you're
you're not vegan? Have you thought about that, Soy Pill? You're
like literally not a vegan. How about we have that conversation
instead? Uh, cool. Very cool. All right, we're done with this.
At the doorstep is directly a consequence of your own petty grievances.
That's all this was always and forever. I would go so far as
to say that
wait, the world is 70% morons. What's your point? that DG is
like 70% future predators
and they should be avoided at all costs is basically my point.
I would go so far as to say that his
pro- genocide position was directly tailored off of my anti-
genocide position. Like it's all spitebased. It doesn't make
any sense. It's just so incredibly
dumb.
>> here he is. The moment this is uh this is not cool.
This is not cool. Free exact. Okay. Not cool. Not cool. I don't
know about this. >> Or he's been demonetized off YouTube.
>> I feel like my YouTube is going to get um promo banned
soon cuz I got like broad demonetized yesterday for I didn't
even say a video. So, I don't know. I'll appeal it. We'll see
what happens. But
>> I mean, if Kimmel is getting cancelled from ABC, I don't
know. >> I said this for years. Here is Dan bragging. He
took seven figures from you. October 1 to January one should
be 50% of all revenue for the year. Lauo, you are such a Hassan
dick writer. Remember that even if you got hit by a truck today
and died, your dad >> Jesus Imager, am I the only one who
got hit with the high beams there? Holy >> Hassan has lost
his seven figures in ad revenue because of me and you can't do
about it. remember to let Hassan know that he lost seven plus
figures of revenue from me, which is ironic
because once again, the only reason why I ever ran ads was because
I had a contract from Twitch. Twitch doesn't offer those
>> Keep your eyes on Hassan any longer and therefore I
don't run any ads any longer. And even after that, that wasn't
enough. Of course, they still tried to attack the platform. So
swi So Twitch made guys I I literally I was contractually obligated
to make all that money. I was contractually obligated to make
all that money. I didn't just accept the contract where they
gave me like $50 million. I wouldn't have done that guys. Come
on. I was contractually
a political content category which I'm
Right? So therefore you don't see ads. My revenue stream is not
off of ads. The [__] Broadcasting Services sponsored
by you, the viewers. Your voluntary subscriptions keep me editorially
independent. That's it. They only ended up hurting a bunch of
small streamers in the long run.
Okay, it's that simple. Knowing full well that because my political
perspective is not broadly reflected by any mainstream party,
I have always relied on my community.
It's grassroots. It's always been grassroots. You cannot be a
leftist and and uh demand contributions from billionaires and
millionaires. You just can't do that. The more right-wing you
are on this political spectrum, the easier it is for you to get
money from uh shadow donors and and very wealthy people. I'd
say I'd say anywhere in political extremism you can get money
from. You just need somebody who's wealthy. And trust me, there
there are wealthy people with all kinds of insane thoughts. I
wouldn't be shocked if Assan, if he was really putting his like
if Assan threw up a flare and was like, I want to run my own
news network, I think there would be massive money that would
line up behind him to run that news network, right? I think he
could easily get like a pro like socialist like social democrat
democratic socialist like news network started that he would
get a ton of money lining up behind him to get in on the ground
floor of that. If he was like Ben Shapiro was like, I want to
start the leftist Daily Wire. I think people would line up. He
wouldn't quite have the mightest touch money, but it would be
it would be somewhere around there. Okay. China would fund it
maybe.
They could end up getting like foreign money. They they but I
think they could run it off of American billionaires, too. There
are a lot of American billionaires who are very sympathetic to
the stuff Assan is is looking to do, right? A liberal has an
easier time getting big donors to defend them and getting big
institutions to defend them and getting big donors to give them
money than a leftist does. And a right-winger has a much easier
time getting those shadow donors than a liberal does. This is
how it works.
>> This is how it works. No billionaire is going to fund
a prominent content creator who says billionaire should not exist.
It is that simple.
You stopped ads a month or two before October.
Yep. What? A few seconds following the clip from earlier. He
explains how justice works and of course is anti-semitic
>> and then they're issuing subpoenas and like that after
that based on the information of of what you give essentially
that's how justice works. >> Some in Miami Beach gives
a PowerPoint and then a company gets brought to its >> So
you're the one that's presented. >> Okay. I I'm sorry.
That's funny. That's Dude, that's really funny actually.
Because listen, I think I think that's what like Nick Fentes
and Hassan probably Nick Fentes, Hassan, Dan, they probably all
agree on this actually. They probably all think that's actually
how it works. >> I mean, your case against Twitch.
>> Yeah. If your world view is entirely around petty grievances
that one streamer has over another, of course, you're going to
end up doing some idiotic [__] in the process. Idiotic
that ends up harming you in the long run. This is where we're
at. And it's ironic because I always mention this. I mentioned
this for the longest time. I said, "Look,
if apolitical and liberal adjacent content creators are consistently
focusing on their left flank and attacking their left flank and
smearing their left flank, then obviously there's going to be
a lot of people who associate th uh the left flank with those
smears. And you might find a little bit of success in that in
that process. You might actually uh humiliate uh leftists and
Marxists or or present them as these like scary people.
But what you're doing in that process is you're you're legitimizing
the people to your right flank because now you're the the people
to the right who I mean I think you could do both at the same
time. It's just like the degree to which you're going at them.
And does it make sense? Like after you if Hassan, you know, ran
into the dirt, you took seven fig. I don't think Dan's even that
far off that he could have taken like seven figures in income
from Hassan by taking the ads away, right? But it's like that's
a win. You won. You you like punished him for all of the [__]
right? You've actually just punished him for all of it. You've
totally won. And for you to keep just going and going and going
and going on it until you like get him banned, I feel like that's
like there are just other places you could put your focus. my
opinion >> might despise you in other circumstances are
now aligned with you in attacking the left. So even if you actually
achieved success
in that process even if you've completely eradicated the left
son stopped ads before that I don't even think you have the option
to stop ads completely anymore. So, he might have stopped doing
like uh bigger ad contracts or something, but I think I think
Twitch runs their ads no matter what. You have to deal with it,
>> And take the money. Even if you completely eradicated
the left, then the right is going to come after you. >> And
we are there now. The left is not actually successfully defeated,
but it doesn't matter. You're still attacking the left. These
people present themselves as like these brilliant people, these
skilled political beings, but they focus on petty grievances.
It's all about ego. That's all this is. He felt this man right
here who has done a ton of awful nonsense attacking anyone to
marginally left his position for daring to to ever criticize
him, has spent most of his career in the last 6 years
actively going after the left. And at times he goes after the
right as well, but mostly he's spent his time opposing people
like myself.
God, I hate that I'm actually agreeing with this on there here.
I don't know that I agree with this and I think you're you can
do good criticisms of anybody you come across. I would say
if you are a politically inclined person, if you spend more or
like a sign significant portion of your time hitting your own
inroup, that's probably not helpful to your political project.
I think it's just realistically you have to look at people who
do that and you probably think okay this is actually somebody
who is more working towards their own goals their own aandisement
their own uh you know enrichment their own clout chasing I I
don't know how to say it like they're looking to grow themselves
right they're not really looking to grow like that movement they're
looking to grow themselves I think that's pretty easy to say
yes you would argue that Hassan is not in that group in the group
that he attacked
you could say he's not going after himself but you could would
also say I that at various different points sort of advertised
himself as somebody who attacks right-wingers, right? And he
phases in and out of that.
But I think
JTO describing Hutch. I don't think that that's bad
necessarily cuz probably what actually man
I know that Hutch seems that way. Hutch is unfortunately there's
like a big appetite for people who will criticize Hassan. Okay.
Who will do the Hassan is bad line and it's Yeah. I feel like
I'm feel like Hutch has good intentions. I feel like Hutch can
grow out of that. Okay, Hutch has good people around him. Hutch
will grow out of that stuff. It seems like it needs to be done
right now. I don't know how badly it needs to be done and we'll
see. That hasn't actually given him any sort of prominence whatsoever.
The son is bad because there is no world view. There is no real
future that you want. There is no perfect society, a perfect
design that you have in mind. It's just pure reactionary. This
is a problem with centrism in general.
It's a huge there's a huge demand for Hana's bad stuff. Mad NLT,
I'll be real. When I like broke off from when when I basically
was no longer in like Destiny's orbit, I knew that I could easily
just farm Hana's bad for like the rest of time. I could have
done the pro ethan anti-hassan thing. I could have kept a massive
audience. I could have made like a bunch of money doing that.
I think I think it was very easy. I knew all the talking points.
I'm better at doing the anti-hisan propaganda than basically
anybody else. Okay. I was just better at it. I I'm sorry if that
sounds like egotistical. I was just better at it. I knew where
the lines were. I knew actually some of the political arguments.
I could actually argue these things without just, you know, giving
up a whole bunch of like attack surfaces back for the other side
to like come back at me for, right? Um but I it just felt like
lazy. It felt like it wasn't helpful. Felt like boring. It felt
It honestly felt disingenuous at that point. So,
I don't know. We go We go off in our own direction. Okay. Hassan
is bad sometimes. That's the new plan. Okay. Sometimes Hassan
is actually bad and we'll we'll get there eventually. >> Okay.
This is why lose to the right all the time because the right
even if we disagree with them and I certainly do have a world
view.
They have a grand design
and they are constantly advocating for said grand design. They
are not directionless.
They are moving the country towards that project. It is a fascist
project and they are successfully moving that this country in
that direction and we're there now. But centrist look to that
and say you know extreme right and the extreme left are just
the same. I am the moderate here. not realizing that year overyear
the right gets more reactionary, more radical and pushes the
Overton window further and further to the right. So the cent's
position becomes more I think this is like totally discounting
the cultural window, the cultural zeitgeist to where it was like
four years ago or 5 years ago pretending that wasn't like Hassan's
group and people ideologically aligned with Hassan who pushed
that. I think that's crazy. Okay, you guys during CO times had
just a total death grip on on the American Overton window. Okay,
you had a total death grip on it. And because of how far you
guys went with that death grip, there's a big backlash now. So
I I think man, I don't know. It feels like it feels like this
is sort of pretending this is an everpresent threat. It's always
been there. I I don't think so. I think it's been a back and
forth a lot of the time. Not that that really changes whether
or not he's going to oppose it. I'm just saying that like he's
got this view that like oh it's always been a dire situation.
It will always be a dire situation. I think I think there's like
a healthy back and forth well unhealthy back and forth that goes
on. Okay. In American politics. Let's see here. Hutch does have
a timing I wanted to read this this message from before. Hutch
does have a timing argument to be fair. He's focusing on the
lefty criticism until the midterms and then he wants to shift
focus. Or so he says at least. The unfortunate thing for Hutch
is he doesn't understand. Okay, Ni was right. All right. When
you stare into the abyss, the abyss stares back. He's going to
make a bunch of people, a bunch of enemies of a group that he's
ideologically aligned with in a lot of ways. And he won't be
able to just go back. He will get a lot of criticism from those
people. He will find himself fighting those people, like fighting
in the muck to pull away from those criticisms. You can't just
sit there criticizing people like saying they're harmful to your
country, harmful to your democracy for weeks and weeks and weeks
and weeks. And then you go, "Actually, now I'm not interested
in you anymore." You can't do that. That doesn't work. Those
people are still interested in you, buddy. Those people are still
going to be pretty mad at you.
Hutch is not in with the lefties. Well, Hutch would understand
because I watch Hutch get like kind of dumpsters in these arguments
with Pisco and Josiah and a bunch of other people that there
are a lot of overlaps in terms of policy. There's way more overlap
in policy with somebody
sorry with somebody like Hassan than there is with Charlie Kirk
and he has to deal with that reality, right? That's why he would
say unless he unless the message I highlighted was just a lie.
That's why he would move away from lefty criticism once midterms
are coming around, right? is because he understands he has more
overlap with those people. He has he has actually some common
ground with those people where he kind of lacks it with the right-wingers.
But I'm saying that you can't just criticize people and say they're
harmful to like your your party, your country for weeks and months
and then when you're like done you go, "Okay, I'm done. Truce."
Those people might not want a truce. Those people might hate
you now. Those people might come after you over everything. Now
you're going to go pick pick fights with right-wingers and the
leftwingers going to be mad at you. They're going to attack you
from the other side. you. That's why maybe it might just make
sense, a lot more sense to have Josiah's position where you just
don't punch left ever, right? Maybe cuz then Josiah doesn't have
a whole bunch of people gunning for him, okay? He just sits there
making his his mightest touch his mightest touch stew. Okay,
I want to call it slop. I'll call it stew. He makes the stew.
People like the stew. People come for the soup. Okay, and then
they go home. It's a much simpler life. this is the issue >> actually
caring about deplatforming or do you think I mean I'm going to
be honest your community uh your podcast host Dan Saltman has
been involved in mass letter campaigns to people like Richie
Torres to get people deplatformed and I'm obviously a friend
to Hassan uh I agree with you on some things I agree with Hassan
on some things I'm kind of in the middle on that progressive
end uh however I do feel like there's been some content creators
uh Asmin Gold H3H3 all those kind of >> this is the thing
that I never understand by the way because it's like when people
say I agree with Assan on some things and I agree with Destiny
on some things. I will never understand it because like the things
that you agree with me on like if you're progressive, you probably
just agree with me and that's it, right? Like what what could
you possibly agree with Destiny on? Because everything that he
has designed when he has tried to create this like unique space
in the progressive side of politics is just anti-me. >> Not
just anti- Hassan, I understand why Hassan sees it that way.
Okay, cuz Vos kind of went to the fortress and stopped interacting.
It's spite based. It's definitely spite based. I'd say that's
a little too far. Okay, Destiny hates a lot of people. All right,
he he bases his like positions on whoever he's fighting with
at any given time. All
>> I I wouldn't say he's just anti-Hassan. That's probably
too far. >> All right, thank you for the primer. Let's
go. 10 months, guys. We're live on Twitch right now. Twitch.tv/jdk
pinned the link in the kick chat. Throw your primers. Okay, throw
primers. Any primers. Any primers at all if you're watching.
Throw primers,
bro. I don't know what's wrong with me. I can't watch Destiny
anymore. I find him so stomach turning. I Yeah, it's that's the
way it is, man. I I get it. I get it. I get it. You know what
I can do? I can read legal documents, though. We might be doing
that later today. I think we're going to do that later today.
We'll see. I'm not 100% sure, but I think so. I think it's going
to be legal document time. >> Like what? To be able to
say the slurs or something? I don't know. I don't really get
it. who have all been involved in this push to deplatform people
and I feel like it's now coming back to bite you in the butt
for example. I mean your name is being mentioned in congressional
hearings now. I'm just wondering do you feel any responsibility
for that? >> I think there's a huge difference between
deplatforming somebody by pressuring a platform to take action
on something versus Whoops. versus like the FCC uh and >> Yeah,
except he also mentioned Richie
Dan Solman didn't just try to do a platform, a deplatforming
initiative by using the ADL, which is ridiculous because the
moment that you use the ADL, you're not pressuring the platform
directly. You're pressuring a a a advocacy group that has a lot
of institutional persuasive power because they have Congress
persons that they can rely on. So that in and of itself is a
is a redirection
that does not make sense. Donald Trump pressuring organizations
to do things. >> We agree on that for sure. >> Yeah.
I mean, I I think people have a right to have their voices heard
on things people have. >> Uh this is not actually true,
Schle. I or at least it I feel like it used to be true, but I
I have a hard time actually going back to this point. I don't
think this is actually true. I think he actually just lies and
then he he or at least he has on this one where a bunch of people
are like, "Hey, why did you say conservatives should be afraid
of getting killed?" So they pressure Donald Trump to make different
decisions. And it's like he's like actually I just think everybody
should have a healthy fear of political violence. And it's like
that's just you're just gaslighting these people. You're literally
just lying to them like openly. What what the be deplatformed
from things, you know, whether I agree or disagree sometimes.
I mean, it is what it is. But um I think it's Yeah, I think it's
fundamentally a different conversation than what we saw happened
just recently with Kimmel and the entirety of the Conservative
party supporting it. I think is a is a very scary thing. Yeah.
But but I mean like like there are some things that people think
they have like an absolutist position on, but their position
is a lot more malleable. They just haven't seen it like tested
yet. Like all of us agree in some level of deplatforming, right?
Like if some guy were to go live on a YouTube stream and he was
just abusing dogs all day just like, you know, punch him in the
head, I think everybody like, "Well, this guy should probably
be banned." Like like there's going to be some level where we're
all like, "Well, this is probably not >> Yeah, except
you're talking about someone who has an anti-Israel position."
That's I agree with that. That's my position as well.
Also, one is a a criminal act for the record. Does he pretend
not to know what Dan's doing or does he genuinely not know he's
tweeting at Torres and Loomer? I think he he it's both. No, he's
very aware. He's very aware of what Dan's doing. Okay. At all
times, he's very aware cuz there are a lot of people around him.
I was one of these people who were just like, "Hey, could you
get this guy under control? This is like crazy. I don't I don't
know what's going on here, okay? Like, this looks really bad."
There are a lot of people around him who are like, "Hey, could
you could you get this? Stop letting him use your community for
this. It's an illegal criminal act for good reason." What's crazy
here? >> I'm not doing that. And you're equivocating
my commentary.
That is now the popular commentary. That is now the popular position.
For the record, you said the term topspeak the other day. Could
you define that? I have no idea what that is. I don't think I've
ever said that. Unless I misspoke or you misheard me.
What the is top speak? You think I Oh, cop speak.
Is that what you You did say it. Why Why is it that you immediately
go You did say it. I think you misheard me. I said cop probably.
when referencing
when referencing the the uh the Tyler Robinson text messages
where he says like
uh where he calls uh the the police vehicle a squad car or even
refers to his own car as a vehicle
like saying things along why is it always us mishearding misharing
and you never speak misspeaking well considering that I also
first said I probably misspoke you are literally mishering and
this guy also misheard the other chatter. Yes, cop.e. I didn't
hear what the chatter said. I thought he wrote cop speak. So
maybe both of these instances is an unfortunate byproduct of
misering,
including but not limited to the fact that I already count I
already factored in that I might have misspoken.
>> Kill kill these first
in a video game. These chatters get them in Minecraft. Line them
up on the wall. Okay, Hassan's so right right now. I don't even
know what those chatter said. I've not really been paying attention.
Hassan is just correct though. Okay, I know he's correct.
Han Hassan won. Chatter suck. Chatter suck. >> Ask yourself
why immediately you take this uh
this this antagonistic tone.
>> The brother got three Guide. He got He didn't even just
get one guide. He's getting three Guide. This guy's
hitting three different chatters at the same >> Where is
that coming from? This is just true. Sweatpants freedom. We all
know this. We all know this.
>> Oh, baby at triple. Yeah. Let's >> Okay. You know,
like watching Hassan, you know, climb a chair with his chat when
Houthies are hijacking ships in the ocean and saying that they're
based in awesome. I think it's an insanely unhinged thing to
watch on >> Oh, is it? Is it? That's interesting. >> I
think it is unhinged. Yeah. Unfortunately, you can't get away
from this one. Okay. The love for them kidnapping those people.
I think the thing that Hassan does is he totally disconnects
the fact that like humans are getting kidnapped. He's like, "Oh,
it's so cool that like a radical group is is doing like actual
military operations in the Red Sea so that they can like fight
back against Israel." That's where his mind is. He can't possibly
conceive of those like human beings, those sailors who got kidnapped.
I think that's more what it is,
but it's still crazy. As opposed to what you do, which is watching
Israel do a genocide and go, "It's based and awesome." I think
the >> I don't I don't know that that's anybody's opinion.
Okay. I don't I haven't heard that opinion. That might be a joking
thing. I don't think that the opinion is actually it's based
in awesome. Okay. Let's be a little bit we be a little fair.
Okay. You be a little >> Anti-genocide position which is
luckily I don't even have to to
uh to to say that this is like just not only the moral position
but now I can say it's the popular position as well. The anti-genocide
position is the popular position. Yes. The only foreign nation
in the region that is actively trying to penalize Israel for
doing a genocide is on the right side of history.
It's that simple. It's that simple. The biggest problem here
for Pesty, aside from, you know, his proclivity towards engaging
in uh in in really horrible actions on that front in his own
personal life, is that he chose the wrong horse to back.
He thought
that he could just maintain
the pro-Israel position, the pro- genocide position, and he would
never actually arrive at a >> It's funny that Desi kind
of ran into the same thing that someone like Camala Harris did,
where like you have a position that kind of ends up being wrong.
And it's not that you keep supporting that position. It's not
that you even hold that position still. It's that you've never
come out and gone like, "Oh, that was a mistake." Or, "You know what?
I backed off of that entirely." You don't really do that. and
you're not loud about it. So, people just kind of keep attributing
that position to you. Destiny is still the Israel guy. And like
I think probably if you were to listen to him, I feel like probably
he's probably said, "Oh, you know, I don't approve of these actions.
I don't approve of those actions." But he's never come out and
said, "I was wrong for advocating this direction and it went
a different way than I expected and obviously the results have
been disastrous." If he said something like that, I mean, maybe
that hurts him, but it would be respectable and people would
stop calling him like the Israel guy. people are okay with like
forgiving somebody who made a mistake, but if you just kind of
like minimize all of these things, if he did that, he would have
been wrong. I know, but like that's what I did. I was just like,
dude, I kind of supported Israel and that was disastrous. Like
that clearly it went horribly. But when I started when I started
like talking to people about that at the start of October 7th
or the end of o the start of October and the the start of November
in 2023,
I was saying like, yeah, there's like a line where where deaths
happen, right? up to a certain point I could support Israel,
but like after it's like 10 to one on casualties, like that's
my hard cut off. I don't support you anymore. Like that's a hard
cut off by the way. That's not like a That's not like um oh well
is still holding these areas. No, it's like after you've killed
10 times more people than got on October 7th. 10 to1. That's
the most I can that's the best exchange rate I can give you for
Arabs. Okay. 10 to one. I ain't going a dollar beyond that. All
right. That's the best exchange rate you're going to get for
me. You don't get any better. and then you have to go home.
>> Unique moment in time where the large majorities of
the public would say, "Hey, that's reallyed up." He thought,
"Isn't it like 100 to1 now?" I think it's like 50 to1. I think
it's like 50 to1. But it is more than 10 to one now. I think
it's like 50 to1 or it maybe it is 100 to1. I actually don't
know. What is it 1,200 people and uh it's not 100,000 dead, right?
It's like I can't remember the exact numbers to be honest with
you. >> He could gesture vaguely depressing to look at
>> pre-established American foreign policy uh positions
and say Israel is doing the right thing. It's not a genocide
and anyone 600,000 380,000 children. No shot. I don't think so.
That could be displaced. That's not That's not dead. That's not
dead. 600,000 dead. No way. Egging. Okay. Rock surgeon. That's
lowhanging fruit. That's on the last UN report. There's no way.
Really? That's That's insane. If that would Someone told Destiny
600K at the live event, so that must be true. Estimated 200k
now, but we don't know.
Wait, is 600k like a number from like possibly this is like the
highest it could go? Was this Don Luke tweet? Alex Jones just
went nuclear and challenged liberal streamer Destiny to a raw
fist fight over his disrespect against Charlie Kirk and calling
for death of conservatives. Alex Jones is requesting for the
rawest unfiltered fight in American history. No gloves, no rules,
last minutes.
Dude, this is not fair. Hold on. I've watched Alex Jones. Alex
Jones is like, "Yeah, he's juiced to the gills right now." Okay,
this would not be a fair fight. All right, this would not be
cool. He's probably got like a 150 lbs on Destiny. He would him
up. And that's like beyond the fact that Destiny has the like
reaction speed, the speed overall of like a much older person.
Okay, he's been sitting in a chair for like 10 years, like 15
years. Like there's no no Destiny. Hold on. Sweatpants freedom.
Destiny will never be able to fight Alex Jones. He has not engaged
in athletics early enough in life. He does not have the the muscle
memory um any like coordination in his body to do that. I guarantee
you there's just nothing. There's nothing there. Right? He could
never fight even with massive amounts of training steroids. It
would never work. He's never he never had his brain developed
to learn how to throw punches, to learn how to do anything, right?
Like you don't you need to pick that up early in life. It's so
difficult to pick any of that up late in life. You pretend Alex
is a carpet that needs to be Okay,
>> here. Hold on. Let's uh let's give this a quick listen.
We'll cut back into Hassan for a little bit and then maybe we'll
do the other stuff. I've got some other politics stuff I kind
of want to get in. I might sneak this in in the middle before
I go back over to the the legal documents. Okay. I want to do
I might want to show what what is it articles on? Yeah, I think
I want to watch the articles on the Jimmy Kimmel stuff. The Nextar.
I got a New York Times article on Jimmy Kimmel and the Supreme
Court rulings that set precedent for free free speech protections
from government threats. I wanted to do a video on the NextStar
merger. And then there's I I want to watch I want to read both
of those articles on stream and then we'll see. Okay, we'll see.
We'll probably go back to the court docs after. All right, that's
the plan. That's the direction we're going in. Buckle in. >> Hell,
I didn't get to this. >> Buckle in. Buck. Lock in. Buckle
up.
>> Get ready. Okay, we're doing more >> Destiny,
that scumbag piece of filth celebrating Charlie's death and saying
more Republicans need to die to intimidate us. That's terrorism.
That's calling for terrorism. Elon Mus call for his arrest. You
got free speech, but you don't have saying we go out and target
and kill people to silence him. That's
>> um anti antiaxium.
Okay. Whatever your name is, did you engage in any kind of athletics
from the time you were like five to 15 or were you just like
a total homebody? Didn't do anything. didn't really go to gym
cuz I I feel like Destiny probably skipped nearly every gym class
from middle school onwards. Like there's a big difference, right?
>> computer nerd. Okay. Well, maybe >> that's terrorism.
That's terroristic threats.
And I'm telling you, I just got a gut feeling that guy's not
going to be too happy very soon. People are sick of this crap.
>> Okay, that's not
I'm so mad that this guy called for for Charlie for death. I'm
so mad that he celebrated Charlie's death and I've got a feeling
that someone's going to take him out right away. Shut the up.
Shut up.
Why Why are these people so bad at just being like the moral
person once in their entire lives? Like, what are you doing?
You're whatever. >> He talks about stalk people and plan
to kill them and their families and all this other stuff. Try
to act all scary and tough with those little wild beady eyes.
Reminds me of the serial killer in Dirty Harry. They have a tour
where they were stalking Kirk around the country. >> That's
him. That's Alex Jones. >> All this crap. I mean, it's
just it's just disgusting. And they've taken our kindness for
weakness and it's just not going to go on forever. Not calling
for the offensive violence against this guy. >> They're
doing
this is like the most I just have to explain to you guys. This
is like the most offensive thing Alex Jones can show with regards
to death. He's like this is who this person is. Look at this.
Look at this disgusting human. It's just regular footage of Destiny
on stream. Look at this disgusting beady serial killer looking.
Right. It's just like normal Destiny footage. The footage Destiny
would use in his own like highlight reels. That's rough, man.
>> But I got a sneaking suspicion. He's already done a
lot of stuff to be under investigation. I wonder what's on those
hard drives. I got a real
I wonder what's on those hard drive, right?
Oh [__] >> Oh, good feeling. Something tells
me that'd be real informative.
>> Oh boy. So, >> obviously to me looks like he's
on methamphetamine. I'm not saying he is, but he's a >> legal
legal methamphetam piece of filth.
I challenge him to bare knuckles boxing match. No limit. He can
wear brass knuckles. I'll go barefisted. >> Oh, he's giving
him an advantage. >> Did that a few days ago? I hadn't
heard anything with the big tough man. Brass knuckles, punk.
See how you do. Let's get in the ring right now. I'm an old man,
too, son. You going to beat the hell out of me so easy with those
brass knuckles. You're so tough,
so mean, so strong. Look at those eyes. Think he's so powerful.
He has delusions of what he can do to people. He has no
>> So sick of cowards playing in a man's >> Alex
Jones is funny as Okay, just remember Alex Jones is a caricature.
Okay, this is a caricature.
That's what Alex Jones is. He's not
He's just goofing. He's just goofing. It's just a joke. >> Alex
Jones just tipped $5. >> Oh Jesus. >> Something that
told me to check his hard drive was Destiny himself. >> This
is This is also true. Okay. He's the one who said he had that
stuff. Oh boy. Oh, thank you for that link. All right, we're
going to watch a little more of the Hassan stuff and then we're
onward and upward some other [__] Okay, Jesse doubles
down, supports Hassan deplatforming, responding to Hassan's coverage.
Oh, >> one that actually is is trying to >> Have
we gotten past this coverage yet? What is this? This is processing
processing. Processing processing
We'll see what he says.
Fight back. >> It's going to be about terrorism versus,
you know, domestic like foreign terrorism, domestic terrorism.
versus defense. He's going to have some lines to make. Right.
>> Okay. So, what ended up happening is what he was trying
to do to me for years and years and years has with his own allies,
as a matter of fact, partially because of his own allies and
their endless interest in aligning with [__] fascist
Republicans want to take >> just as a heads up any on my
subreddit that's talking about how Hassan is like an ally now.
We need to unite or whatever [__] No, the Trump admin
taking out people like this, you know, is would be a dream godsend
for us. People like Hassan are the are these >> I think
he knows he's gone. I think he's he's just trying to Listen,
this is um this is a kamicazi attack. Okay, his jet got hit and
he's aimed it at the air carrier, the the USS Hassan [__]
Okay, he's he's he's going down rapidly. He's got nothing else
he can do. He's he's kamicazing. Okay, he could eject. He doesn't
want to eject. He's just kamicazing into this guy. These are
the controlled opposition the liberals have to deal with relating
to the Republican party. They would never ever seriously come
after or harm any of Hassan's >> Actually demonetized.
>> Oh, hold on. No, I they went after me because I'm actually
a threat to them. They'll never go after Hassan cuz Hassan's
going to drag you down. The only reason they came for me is because
I'm actually the problem. You need to unite behind me. >> He's
on YouTube. Okay. So, what
are the
These are the controlled opposition the Liberals have to deal
with relating to the Republican party. They would never ever
seriously come after or harm any of Hassan's platform >> was
actually demonetized.
>> He's trying to he's trying to stoke the outrage. He's
trying to get this clip to go around. So, let let me explain
it to you, okay? He's trying to get this theory going out to
people who watch him, his his really loyal viewers, right? who
are going to go out and watch people like Pisco or Hutch or IRI
and he wants that line to be getting fed to those people as much
as possible in a seemingly decentralized fashion, right? In like
a like from the audience like, oh man, they're just going after
him because he's he's like actually helpful and Hassan they they'll
just leave Hassan there forever. He wants that narrative flowing
out into the world. Uh it's pretty obvious, you know, it's just
is pretty obvious. Um is Hassan controlled opposition? I would
say Hassan does do things. gay. His proterrorism rhetoric does
feed into right-wing, you know, campaigning in a way that that
helps them and is somewhat similar to Destiny, but he has actual
goals. He has actual principles seemingly that he stands behind,
right? With Destiny, it's not like that. With Destiny, he's just
like this last thing with Charlie Kirk is just totally immoral,
totally lacking in any principle. He's just like, "Oh, I want
to make a stand here. Why Why don't you guys stand with me? Why
won't you stand with me?" So, I I think Hassan can do that sometimes.
Son can be a like a useful idiot for the right, but that's probably
most like pretty principled,
you know, leftist or or right-wing activists. I would say they
can be a useful idiot for the other other side. I'd say there's
very few people who I would support being that without significant
benefits. Zan is a pipeline for young people. I don't know what
Destiny is doing recently. I don't know what the goal is here.
I've got no idea what the long-term plan is. So, it's a little
different. Anyway,
go back. We'll keep watching a little bit of Assad >> against
Israel's genocide is actually morally not in the right but in
the wrong. And they're all terrorists and they should be evaporated.
>> Whoa. Evaporated. What? Huh? Huh? What? >> LMO,
we got one. No, he's he's joking. He's being sarcastic. He says,
"Counter argument. You're straw manning so hard right now." >> You
give Destiny way too much credit. I give Destiny way too much
credit. I've never heard that. I haven't heard that one in a
long time. Oh boy. That's a criticism I haven't gotten in a long
>> As a def fan, you're wildly misrepresenting his point.
You're supposed to hear it from a secondary source, not from
his mouth. You disinfo agent. He backed himself into a corner.
And in the past, And in the past, instead of offering like a
nuanced perspective on any given issue that pertains to American
foreign policy,
uh, and and be able to bastardize his opposition's position,
mine, like when it came to Ukraine, and falsely claim that I
was actually against Ukraine or I was pro-Russia, all these different
things. he was able to get a lot of mileage out of that. So,
I think he did that with Israel as well, thinking that he would
have the same kind of support.
Of course,
not only was that a bastardization for uh of my viewpoint on
Ukraine, >> I should just say, okay,
I'll I'll just back this up. All right. I feel like with the
only way I Hold on, let me uh let me pull >> Let me pull
this previous streamable back up here. >> Actually demonetized
on YouTube Okay, with regards to this clip, all right, I should
point out as well that the defense people had of Destiny, the
people they tried to say was like, "Oh, um, you know, I I might
not agree with this. Jesus, what is the music that's playing
here? Shut the [__] up." Okay, people will disagree
with Destiny and they're like, "But I hate that the administration
would do this to him." Destiny has none of those morals. He doesn't
have that moral position whatsoever. He's just like, "Actually,
it'd be awesome if if MAGA like if they like locked him up, if
they deplatformed him. That would be so great for all of us.
There's just none of that same like principled attachment to
free speech. There's nothing. It's just nothing there, right?
YouTube is goofy. Even though he did get a lot of mileage out
of that and a lot of people still to this day, especially on
Reddit, think I'm like pro-Russia, which is so insane, but what
are you gonna do?
But genocide is so black and white that
his perspective
on Israel, the unconditional support to Israel became unimaginably
unpopular. >> Get ready for the gaslight. He was joking.
He's not joking. >> And now here we are.
His principles. This dude again. I hate to I don't know why I
say I hate to. Okay. Vos Vos is just kind of like
I got to reset on Bosch. I got to find a way to reset on this
guy. Okay, cuz what he called the spitebased thing, the spitebased
thing is just so accurate is like the most accurate analysis.
It's it it's just correct every single time
media platform especially by their own rules to say you can't
champion terrorist violence. So yeah, I mean there's going to
be some level of like obviously disagreement that people should
be allowed to have across social media platforms, but I think
it's gotten really extreme on a lot of them right now. So you
>> he said he said my
contextualization
of the onsah movement in Yemen's actions against the genocidal
state of Israel is akin to animal abuse.
Okay, that is what he just tied this argument up with. At some
point people have to recognize that this is not good argumentation
whatsoever. Okay, just because the speaker is confident doesn't
mean >> bro, why are all your streamers degenerates? Hey,
I don't want to like Bosch. Okay, but unfortunately, this guy
just pers the orb and and divines the the secret truths of the
universe. All right, I listen, there's a point at which I'm like,
hey, I don't like the guy. I don't like like a lot of the things
he's into, but somehow
somehow some divine force decided that the guy who puts geckos
on his is the one who can see the future. I don't make the rules.
I don't have that power. You think I'd give it to the guy who
puts de geckos on his and takes pictures for other women? I'm
not That's not me. That's not my decision. Okay. There's some
there's some
universal concept that decided that this was this is my champion.
This guy who puts the gecko on his dick, that's my champion.
I'm sorry. That's that wasn't my choice. That the contents of
the the the things that he's saying is actually appropriate.
You should be able to think and reflect and think critically
on what he is actually saying. I'm I'm honestly not paying attention
to what Destiny's saying here at all. So wait, so the goblin
drawings is part of some kind of divination? No, just all of
Hassan, sorry. All of Vos's positions ended up being like what
a lot of liberals are at now. Vosch was telling you that Republicans
are evil fundamentally. They cannot be negotiated with and you
need to arm yourself like two and a half, three years ago. That
was V Bosch pondered the orb. Okay. Bosch pondered the orb and
he knew where things were going. All right.
And I'm just saying that like maybe maybe he grew too too maybe
he grew too arrogant and whatever divine force was showing him
the future had to humble him and so they made him open his taxes
folder. Okay.
But now he has been humbled and he's back. He's back and on on
the way.
He's back on the path. >> That's it. It's just debate,
bro.
Through and through. That's why I've always said he's like the
left's Ben Shapiro. Well, not even the left, but like a liberal
centrist Ben Shapiro. And apparently they were heckling him pretty
hard. I saw the the
distributor himself, Dom Lucre,
>> also making five. I wasn't going to tell anyone, but
uh we put the secrets of the universe behind horse featuring
anime characters.
Bosch was one of the few to find it. >> That's not true.
A lot of other people would have found it. Okay.
I will say though, the choice to make Bitcoin take off after
being like prolific in the purchasing of child uh of child abuse
materials, that was a weird one. Okay. Whatever whatever force
made that happen. Kind of weird to just make all those rich for
some reason. All right. But we had that conversation time.
distributor or recipient pedesty here
>> because so many people that hate me have this uh strange
obsession with that
>> He's describ he's going to describe the
>> times when they're fighting amongst themselves it turns
into violence
Very strange.
Anyway, here are some hecklers uh when he was trying to do this
change my mind thing.
>> Not half as many as you, sir. >> Oh, your mic's
not on. [__] >> dude. I'm not laughing at that,
by the way. Disavow. I'm laughing at Hassan knows he can't laugh
at that. Hassan knows he's not supposed to laugh at that. And
he just got caught laughing at that. Okay, Hassan, what are you
do? He also just broke the toos, by the way. >> Lucifer
just tipped $5. >> Uhoh. The Bitcoin one was me. >> Oh,
hold on. Hold on, guys. Kick.com/jk
on Twitch. That That's where the stream ends. Okay. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Sorry. Sorry, Twitch viewers. Sorry,
Twitch viewers. That's uh that's where the stream's got to go
away. All right. That's uh
It's not good. That's not good. That's not good. Uh
we're going to delete that VOD. That VOD can go away. Bye-bye.
We're We're on kick only, guys. Okay. Jesus. I I do not have
the advantage that Hassan has. Okay, I do not have the protections
that Hassan has. And I just realized that that's a clear Twitch
to violation that I am not going to let sit there. All right,
we we're okay on kick. They're not going to get us on kick, but
on Twitch, that's a bad one. >> That often times when they're
fighting amongst themselves, it turns into, >> you know,
violence,
>> Very strange.
Anyway, here are some hecklers uh when he was trying to do this
change my mind thing.
>> Not half as many as you, sir.
>> He covers his face. He knows he covers his face. He
knows he's not supposed to laugh at it. >> It's interesting
because
he said I assume he's coming at this from a far right angle,
right? Like the person who's heckling him, I suspect, is is probably
far right. because he's using the ller. Maybe rightwing, right?
>> But if he's right-wing,
then if he's right-wing and he's saying that, doesn't he realize
that one of the he sucked may or may not have been Nick Fuentes's,
at least by Destiny's own admission?
So, you're kind of doing friendly fire there big time. >> I
mean, I think I think right-wingers have had to come to their
own, you know, their own understanding, their own peace with
Nick Fuentes being gay. Okay. They just don't have a better advocate.
All right. It happened to them with Milo in the early 2010s.
It's happened to them again. Turns out gay people are great at
media. All right. That's not that conservatives have to make
their own fouian bargains. Okay. >> That's the other thing
about, you know,
violence in general. >> All right. All right. I think that's
where we cut it here for the react.
>> We got five. May
>> what? May. May have been. Okay. May. May have been.
May have been.
Seems like the Nick Fentes donation disagrees with the word May,
the categorization of that. All right, I'm gonna pull this Gokano
clip and then Oh, and then we're we're reading for a quick minute.
Well, we'll see. Maybe I might read at the end of stream. We'll
see.
>> we we have a Gokanaru clip from Snotnose Swagger over
here. Snottnose Swagger SN a little bit. Well-known clipper in
the community. Okay, got a clip from Gokanaru stream. Let's check
this out. Chronic Sonic. That's the guy. I knew it was I I thought
it was Sonic something, but Chronic Sonic. Yes, Chronic Sonic.
I knew that, by the way. I totally knew that. I totally knew
that. Did he get the official reason for his demonetization?
Destiny was openly doxing people on YouTube just a couple weeks
ago, including Chatters.
Yeah, 100%. Yo, Sema 4, I ain't a Destiny apologist, okay? Destiny
totally has nuked his credibility. He has destroyed
a lot of any of the perceived legitimacy that he has. He is in
many ways exhibiting features that I witnessed firsthand with
Tumad. Okay, that's saying a lot.
I think that is
extremely accurate. I don't know that I've heard anybody make
that point. I think a lot of other people who are around Destiny
thinking Supreme and Really I would wonder I would want to ask
them about that because that is actually something that Supreme
and Really both knew Tumat I believe had had like personal like
in real life interactions with him and I think one of their roommates
lived with him or something right and like I think that is so
true that it's very much like Tumad where it's like he keeps
leaning into things that just no purpose right that really didn't
[__] with Destiny anymore he doesn't but I'm saying
that like the the Tumad comparison is very apt to me very interesting
And uh at the end of it all really I understand that he's not
really someone to feel sorry for. Right. Did he get the official
Damn.
All right. Okay. I've got a couple different things here. Let
me let me pull up the docket.